but this morning marks the one week
since russia's invasion of ukraine began
in kiev last night a huge flash lit the
night sky as correspondent charlie
daggetta finished the live report
charlie and his crew are okay russian
forces are continuing their offensive on
the ground moving closer to major cities
from the north east and south one
ukrainian official says a major port
city on the black sea is surrounded
another says russia has captured the
nearby city of kerasen where new video
shows russian troops and vehicles on the
streets the u.n says more than one
million people have now fled the
fighting the fastest refugee exodus of
this century
many of the ukrainians are fighting on
to protect their country chris lipsey is
in the western city of la vie chris good
morning
good morning add to those million
refugees millions more who have been
internally displaced many of their homes
destroyed by indiscriminate russian
attacks
in today's ukraine
the sky is the people's enemy
huge explosions in kiev overnight the
ukrainian government claiming their air
defenses struck down russian missiles
this residential block on the city's
outskirts was also destroyed
in the town of jitomir a similar fate
i hope that my wife was
that
fast
that
in this moment my wife
in heaven and everything was perfect in
his
her life
yet ukraine's president vladimir
zelinski remains defiant
we are beating them off our soldiers our
border guards are militias he says even
ordinary farmers are capturing russian
soldiers daily and they all say the same
thing they don't know why they're here
captured russian soldiers like this
young man when these ukrainians help him
call his mother he bursts into tears
it's a fiery resistance
that's stunned russia and the world the
ukrainian government has even issued
instructions for ordinary civilians to
make molotov cocktails like the pravda
brewery they switched from making craft
beer to craft ballistics says director
terrace muselko
is that putin there yeah you have put in
here holding the nuclear bomb and the
soldiers and the
russian trucks who was with russian flag
and cowered with blood coming here we
need to be aware and we need to be
prepared
to defend our families to defend our
homes
the brewery is also forging hedgehogs
sharpened steel beams that can stop
tanks dead in their tracks and these
nasty little welcome mats called
stingers which can blow out military
tires i see you with the molotov
cocktail and i see the russians with
tanks
it feels like david and goliath
yeah actually we have
world war iii here now in 20th 21st
century
and we stand against the huge army but
we will stand to the last
among those standing ukraine's newest
recruits just a week ago few ukrainians
expected russia would actually invade
now they're the ones pulling the trigger
despite ukraine's resolve russia
continues to tighten the news
specifically in the south where it aims
to cut ukraine off from all of its
seaports not to mention critical
supplies tony
chris let's say for us in la vie chris
thank you very much it's amazing to see
one of our correspondents interviewing
in a casual nature a guy holding a
molotov cocktail it shows you what the
normal is there in ukraine and i'm
thinking about that explosion that
happened behind charlie dagetta we're
grateful his crew is okay we're grateful
charlie's okay and here as we enter week
two of this conflict thousands are dead
and they are not okay every time i keep
hearing the air raid sign it makes a
hair stand up on the back of my neck and
every time you hear a gunfire and
shelling you know somebody may be dying
at that very moment when you're
listening to it but kudos to charlie
daggett and all the reporters who are
covering it you forget
maybe you don't forget but they're in a
dangerous situation as well they're also
risking their lives to bring us this
story yeah that's never lost on me a
good example what you saw happened to
charlie there are so many sources we all
can get our news from um but when you
see the videos of the ukrainian people
with the russian soldiers yes yes yes
that puts things in perspective um there
is a very human level that you can react
to what's going on and just know that
there are people in danger and we hope
that there are and we're talking about a
serious death toll on the russian side
you know u.s officials are estimating
more than 2 000 to put that in
perspective this country lost only 2 500
soldiers in 20 years this is eight days
there in ukraine it's not what they
expected and we'll see if they get out
i'm in mean of the ukrainian people that
said no you can't do this to us we're
going to fight for our country yeah